con el estallido de la guerra de rusia
en ucrania andrei se unió a las unidades
territoriales de defensa un cuerpo de
milicianos ucranianos que son parte de
la resistencia contra la agresión rusa
estoy en mi tierra por eso no tengo
miedo en lo que piensas en los rusos
se pregunta difícil para mí mi papá
nació en rusia mi mamá nació en belarús
conozco a mucha gente en rusia son gente
buena es putin que quiere la guerra
luchen mucho en juego
andrei cuenta que pasa hasta 14 horas en
los checkpoints enfundando un
kalashnikov y controlando que el resto
de los milicianos hagan bien su trabajo
cuál es el problema quieren matarme a mí
a mi familia a mis amigos y nos quieren
despojar de una parte importante de mi
país
mientras el ejército ucraniano se
encuentra en la primera línea de batalla
estos civiles luchan en la retaguardia
levantando barricadas y checkpoint que
sirven para controlar a todos aquellos
que entran y salen de las ciudades
rusia es una guerra no una guerra solo
contra ucrania es una guerra contra
todos los países europeos y todos los
países del mundo control de word el
coronel alexandr no quiere que se diga
su apellido y explica que hay centenares
de civiles armados bajo su mando tenemos
que defendernos somos hombres y tenemos
que hacer todo lo que podamos para
defendernos pero cuando le preguntamos
si tiene miedo de morir el coronel es
contundente no no tengo miedo de morir